two weeks just Magnus Carlson is
talented confident and arrogant and he
knows it thing is I'm so arrogant that
even when he was mating me I didn't
realize realize it when asked who his
greatest rival in chess was he said no
one running on X what am I supposed to
do make stuff up by the way let's
connect on X I'm at news think Link in
description he did list his second
greatest rival as American chess
Grandmaster Hikaru nakam we're simply
better at chess than the others and so
we can make good moves more quickly so
they need to to spend time Carlson is so
confident in his abilities that with
time ticking away at a world
championship event he literally took a
sip of water and then he spent more time
adjusting his chest pieces but beneath
the bravado lies a child prodigy by the
age of two he completed a 50 piece
jigsaw puzzle when he was four he had
memorized the names of most of his
native Norway's 356 municipalities by
eight chess had become his life
initially he really just wanted to beat
his older sister and then he was hooked
devouring chess strategy books in his
dad's Library it took him only a year to
beat his dad Henrik for the first time
he credits skiing as a secret weapon to
winning in chess helping him mentally
reset you went to in the moding for
skiing yeah I went for skiing uh frankly
I mean I don't think I would one today
if I hadn't done that
because I was just so you know sick of
the hotels and they terrible air
everywhere so apart from skiing soccer
and yoga help him keep in Peak physical
and mental shape to handle the rigorous
demands of Chess tournaments he says
most chess games hinge on the final
hours where mistakes are made due to
fatigue the number of moves in chess is
greater than the number of atoms in the
universe I I know what to do I don't
have
to figure it
out he's been called the mozard of Chess
much like the composer's inexplicable
genius Carlson's skills seem
otherworldly in 2004 when Carlson was
just 13 He stunned the World by beating
former Champion Anatoli karpov at a
tournament in rikic the following day
Carlson came close to beating the number
one ranked player Gary Kasparov Kasparov
barely managed to escape with the draw
in the first game and then won the
second the match had a profound effect
on Carlson who a month later became a
Grandmaster the highest title awarded to
chess players by the international Chess
Federation karov briefly became his
coach a few years down the road paying
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
training was a good investment because
Carlson reached world number one at the
age of 19 he has been ranked number one
non-stop since 2011 the international
Chess Federation recognizes him as
arguably the best player in the history
of Chess he has a peak ELO rating of
2,882 the highest ever recorded in the
system used in competitive chess to rate
how good you are based on Tournament
results chess.com lists him as the
second greatest player of all time
behind Gary Kasparov do you agree let me
know in the comments even those who
aren't Avid followers of the game
recognize Carlson's name
he's achieved Celebrity Status oh that
was quick oh that was
bad one of Carlson's biggest assets is
his remarkable memory 60 minutes once
produced a segment in which he played 10
opponents at the same time while not
looking at the chess boards he had to
memorize the positions on all the boards
and keep track of them in his mind as
they changed he won all 10 games a good
memory is a tremendous asset in chess as
it lets you navigate the early game with
confidence recalling countless opening
strategies it's like having a playbook
in your mind ready to deploy any game
plan on the spot but perhaps his biggest
strength is his versatility Grandmaster
Vish Anan said he can be tactical he can
be positional he can be many things kind
of like a dancer who can gracefully
Glide from ballet to the spirited moves
of salsa he defeated Anin to become the
world chess champion for the first time
in 2013 um unbelievable Magnus Carlson
champion of the world this signaled the
rise of a new era of players who grew up
in the age of online chess although
Carlson has benefited from competing
against players online and getting
access to instant game analysis
advantages Legends like Bobby fiser
never had he's been pretty clear that
computers themselves are boring to play
against he refused to play the chess
engine mittens calling it a soulless
computer yet the might of machine is
undeniable Kasparov famously lost
against the IBM supercomputer deep blue
in a series of matches in 1997 in the
final game he was crushed in just over
an hour so while computers stand as
formidable opponents in the realm of
Chess does any human stand a chance
against the might of Magnus Carlson
chess players are believed to Peak
between 35 and 45 years old Carlson is
32 going on 33 at the time of this video
it's hard to believe he may not have
reached his prime even harder to believe
that he may be tired of playing the game
he decided not to defend his title at
the World Chess Championship in 2023
explaining in his podcast I am not
motivated to
play uh another another match I I
feel
that um I simply feel that I don't have
uh a lot to gain I don't
particularly um I don't particularly
like it for the five-time champion it
was akin to abdicating his crown I don't
rule out return in in the future but I
wouldn't wouldn't particularly uh count
on it he's also taken a liking to Poker
though he says he has no Grand Ambitions
there for someone who likes to win above
everything don't count him out of Chess
just yet
yeah trying to guess your opponent's
next move while plotting your best move
feels like one giant logic puzzle I
found that Brilliance logic puzzles have
improved my analytical thinking skills
just taking a few minutes out of my day
has made a huge difference for me and it
can for you too and it's free to try out
brilliant is a website and app where you
can learn math science and computer
science interactively whether you'd like
to brush up one way you already know or
dive into more advanced topics they's
something for everyone you can try out
brilliant for free for 30 days using my
custom link in the description
brilliant.org
newthink the first 200 people who sign
up via my link will get 20% off their
premium subscription unlocking all of
brilliant's courses thanks for watching
for news thinkink I'm Cindy pal